I think you just got a glimpse of the
future of Education the runaway success
of Khan Academy which launched in 2008
should the potential for online learning
to revolutionize K through 12 education
it meant that a great classroom lecture
could be experienced by anyone anywhere
and learning software from companies
like dream lines could act as a personal
tutor we've developed the intelligent
adaptive learning technology that
accelerates student learning 12 years
later classrooms mostly look like they
always have and many teachers are
skeptical that technology can
fundamentally remake classroom
instruction this whole idea of turning
over education to technology takes away
the human element computers have been
used in classrooms since the 1980s by
2000 there was one PC for every five
students in American classrooms in 2008
the same year that Khan Academy launched
the legendary business professor Clayton
Christensen who passed away last week at
the age of 67 co-authored a book
applying his theory of disruptive
innovation to the classroom when used
disruptive Lee software could solve the
problem with students learning at
different speeds while some are bored
others are struggling to keep up
Kristensen and his co-authors wanted to
flip the structure of the classroom and
make it student centric they would watch
online courses given by the world's best
instructors educational apps would game
a file earning helped track progress and
personalize the content teachers could
then use classroom time to help students
tackle bigger more conceptual problems
Christensen and his co-authors predicted
that by 2018 about 50% of high school
classes would be delivered online and
they dismissed the objection that
government bureaucracies and teachers
unions would stand in the way of rapid
change
their prediction didn't come true I
would say the big lesson that I've had
is not that I'm disappointed but just
that it takes a long time to do this
Michael horn who is one of Christensen's
co-authors is a Harvard MBA who
specializes in education technology
you're trying to overthrow literally a
century of policy and practice around
our current school system and all of a
sudden we come along and say wait a
second we're not doing it the right way
schools have continued to integrate
computers into classrooms but Horne says
they haven't brought fundamental change
we think that every student because
they're in fifth grade for example
should be doing the exact same thing at
the exact same time and then we should
test on those exact same things we
literally fund schools based on the
number of minutes that students sit with
seats not how much they learn disrupting
class included a plea to philanthropists
to help fund this disruption foundations
answered that call but with limited
impact take summit learning which is
backed by Mark Zuckerberg and Bill Gates
its goal was to be in 50% of public
schools by 2025 over 100 million dollars
later it's used in just four tenths of
1% although according to the education
news site chalk beat summit declined the
opportunity to be studied by a team of
Harvard researchers it can point to
anecdotal successes such as the
experience of one public middle school
in Washington DC so we got wind of this
program and said like hey let's try it
like let's pilot it summit learning flew
teachers to California for training and
covered the entire cost of the program
we saw just student engagement increase
and actually like behavioral referrals
decrease because students were engaged
100% Denise Edwards tied teachers
performance evaluations to the new
online curriculum as a teacher you want
that control over your classroom like
this is your space this is your baby and
like letting go brings about
fear but Emily Raskin a math teacher at
another DC High School says that the
flipped classroom model ignores the
realities of student behavior I think
that we look at the next big thing that
seems great to adults and assume that
it's going to be the same thing for kids
so if you assign them to watch a video
for example at home one night that is
maybe 10 minutes long by 30 seconds in
if they're not really interested they
just kind of zone out and they come to
school the next day really believing
that they have watched the video in some
schools where summit was implemented two
parents fought to overturn it parents
and students often just don't know what
they don't know about school they don't
know what it could be what opportunities
they might be missing dos meses para la
familia the subjects that we cover and
the electronic apps are science history
geography we do music Spanish math art
according to Clayton Christensen's
theory of disruptive innovation change
happens first in the segments of the
markets so insignificant that nobody is
really paying attention to them but
eventually they grow to overtake the
industry disrupting class gives home
schoolers as an example
Melissa Keegan is a mother of five in
rural Maryland and I'm not I'm not a
teacher I'm not trained to be a teacher
I don't think you need to have that in
order to home-school
if you have apps like these we're living
in this moment I think where we can
reshape the models at the heart of
Education and leverage these tools and
technologies are we on the eve of seeing
the end of the traditional classroom no
reason why why it really can't happen in
every classroom in a man
tomorrow or perhaps Kristensen and horn
are guilty as the saying goes of
mistaking a clear view of the future for
a short distance
the current classroom model may survive
for a long time to come
at least until software gets better at
approximating student-teacher
interactions and when change does occur
chances are it will look nothing like we
had imagined
[Music]